hi I'm Emma I work in the contacts  entrance Rafa district council we're  taking lots of calls but one of the new  services is helping with your food  parcels in connection with the hope so  we're speaking to residents who maybe  aren't on the list residents  [Music]  we make sure that we've checked and  counted ordered than the items that  we've received today that includes  unfortunately fresh fruit and vegetables  [Music]  so we're looking for the premises we're  grouping them together in a delivery  driver so starting off with the furthest  away which would save them and then  highlight in that and I'll be passing up  to the drivers